when actors gush about our makeup
artists and hairstylists we may some
vain but what we really are is grateful
these are the artists who make us look
the part we need to play this year's
nominees brought to life the grace of a
bygone era the aliens of the Marvel
Universe and transformed one of our most
beloved stars into an unrecognizable
villain here are the nominees for
achievement in makeup and hairstyling
Foxcatcher bill Corso and Denis Lydiard
the grand Budapest hotel Frances Hannon
and Merkel near guardians of the galaxy
Elizabeth Yani Georgiou and David White
and the Oscar goes to the grand budapest
hotel
hello I'd like to say thank you so much
the Academy this is a great honor and
secondly I'd like to thank my dear
friend Bill Murray who introduced me to
where seventeen years ago on Rushmore
and of course to thank was without us we
wouldn't be here any of us it's been
such a pleasure working with you over
all these years I'd like to thank my
family of course and all the amazing
assistants who made this possible for
both of us um Julie Darnell and Emma
mash normal web and all my other people
with me thank you so much and I'd like
to thank thank ways such an amazing
movie and a great experience
I'd like to thank my crew Duncan Jarmon
Stephen Murphy dead Malinowski Josh
Weston and I'd like to thank the
legendary makeup artist dick Smith whose
innovation and who passed away last year
his innovation and his generosity has
helped us all raise the bar